-Hey, guys.
I'm so excited about this.
-Look at this outfit.
-Oh, my goodness.
It's the real me.
I'm so excited.
We are riding "The Beast."
[ Growl ]
Actually, I heard
it could get a little wet.
-Oh.
-You guys ready
to ride "The Beast"?
-Yeah!
-Why does it have to
row like this?
-Because we're in water.
-Oh.
-Look at New York.
Oh, my God, look.
Isn't that pretty?
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪
-Bum-bum, bum-bum!
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪
♪ -Don't throw up on me ♪
♪ Don't throw up on me,
don't throw up on me ♪
-Hi, New York.
-Working girl. Working girl.
[ Boat horn blows ]
-Yay!
-Oh!
-Jesus!
-This might be a bad time,
but is the ascot too much?
-No. Give it to me
so I can wrap my head.
-Thank you.
-Karamo, how you doing?
-Oh, no.
-Oh, Jesus Christ!
-Alright.
-Oh [bleep]
-Okay, we get it.
-Oh, my.
[ Laughter ]
-Aim that way.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh!
-No!
Oh, oh, ew!
-It's so hard to make it sexy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-Oh, oh!
-Puking.
-Is he barfing?
-Ooh!
[ Screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-Karamo, are you okay?
-Aah! Jesus Christ!
♪ -Some people wait a lifetime ♪
♪ For a moment like this ♪
[ Indistinct singing ]
♪ I can't believe
it's happening to me ♪
♪ Some people wait a lifetime
for a moment like this ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I'm the king of the Hudson!
[ Cheering ]
-That was so good.
Like, Karamo --
-That was the worst thing ever.
Worst thing ever.
-I actually didn't think
it was that bad.
I didn't even get that wet.
-I know. It was so shocking.
You look pretty good.
-There's, like,
a little drop of --
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
♪ -Come sail away, come sail
away, come sail away with me ♪